meaning my name is Noreen khawaja and
I'm a member of the Department of
Religious Studies here at Yale
it's my delight and my honor to be asked
to have been asked to introduce
professor Donna Gers second of three
Terry lectures this evening before I say
anything more I just want to remind
everyone if they have not already please
turn off your cellular phones because
this lecture is being recorded and also
another reminder that as last time after
the lecture we'll have a reception where
everyone is welcome is just for your
doors to the right there
Wendy doneger is the mayor chair we had
a distinguished service professor of the
history of religions in the Divinity
School at the University of Chicago Dale
Martin my colleague last time introduced
professor Donna Garen gave us a great
sense of her considerable achievements
and her range as a scholar to the many
publications and honors he listed I
thought I'd just mention a few of the
many awards she's received over the
course of her career she was the
recipient of the Martin E marti award
for the public understanding of religion
given by the American Academy of
religion she was given the distinguished
scholar award by the South Asian
literary Association and she will
deliver the Haskins prize lectures at
the American Council of learned
societies next year an honor that
celebrates the distinction and impact of
her long scholarly career professor
doneger was also the recipient in a
slightly different van in 2012 of the
university of chicago's faculty award
for excellence in graduate teaching and
mentoring their highest teaching award
and a factor in this achievement I would
guess is the fact which I've just
learned that she's advised 74 doctoral
dissertations over the course of her
career
I should 74 that finished and I should
say 74 in counting right so on that note
I myself first read her work in my first
year of graduate school in the context
of a required seminar on theories and
methods in the study of religion and
like most courses of this type this one
struggled to bridge the theoretical
interests among a cohort of students
whose fields ranged from Japanese
Buddhism to German Protestantism
Orthodox Jewish theology to medieval
Sufi rituals and the greatest challenge
was getting everyone in the room to
care about the same books but when we
got to Donna Gers 1999 book on myth the
implied spider something changed people
started arguing and giving speeches they
also started thinking in class
somehow Donna Gers work spoke to a room
of budding scholars who had been poised
to think that the text that we were
reading had no bearing on their very
specialized research and her work turned
those disengaged skeptics into fierce
readers whose investment in the sorts of
mythologies she was describing surprised
even them one of the reasons for this
reaction I'd venture to say lay in Donna
Gers incomparable sensitivity to the
metaphorical character of texts her way
of thinking in and through stories
telling stories about ideas and often
very unexpected stories every metaphor
she would be the first to remind us
involves the transgressing of a boundary
taking some meaning or image and
carrying it over into a new space we saw
a good deal of this metaphorical
thinking last time as we heard about the
CIA agents of the artist Shastra and
perhaps more extensively about how the
dharmic ideals of duty and justice were
appropriated and transformed by the
writers of the Kama Sutra and the artist
Astra as we saw how in the interplay of
duty and desire competition and
deception love and political gain these
scriptures which might be seen as
separate and complementary show
themselves to cultivate nuanced and
complex attitudes towards one another
and towards the diverse goods that they
seek professor doneger has promised us
that today things are going to get even
more interesting so without further ado
let's get to it
welcome back today's topic is glossing
anti Dharma with Dharma
Thank You Noreen for summarizing it's
always tricky you know who heard the
first one yesterday the two days ago but
for those of you who didn't that was a
very very good summary of what I tried
to do try to do all my life but also
tried to do on Tuesday so I'll I'll take
it from from there I'll just summarize
very little we saw in my first lecture
that someone added bits of the laws of
Manu to the textbook of politics the
order Shastra and vice versa and that
the Kama Sutra the text of erotic love
borrowed heavily from the arthashastra
so we have these three texts in
conversation this sort of historical
inflation is a common phenomenon among
ancient Indian texts whose robust
intertextuality allows them to grow over
the centuries like palaces and it often
leads to apparent internal dissonance
there are already contradictions within
the laws of Manu that have nothing to do
with the artist Shastra as when Manu
speaks both in favor of and against
eating meat and more broadly in favor of
both animal sacrifice and non injury to
animals and the influence of Manu on the
artist roster and the artist roster on
the Kama Sutra can account for some of
the conflation zuv diametrically opposed
points of view in the artist roster and
the Kama Sutra that we will consider in
this second last lecture
since many ideas taken from money were
eventually stitched into the artist
östra some but not all of the bits of
programming predominate eolr G in the
our testosterone may be attributed to
that revision the artist Shastra you
should have a handout sheet of terms
really the only new one today is at the
very bottom I'll be talking about the
pore of a box a lot but the rest of them
I'll skip over today that moment mainly
from I did them mostly on Tuesday they
are testosterone the kamasutra often
cite the views of older scholars to
contrast with their own views and they
do it in a particular way that is part
of the convention of the game of
Shastras scientific textbooks it's the
custom in the sastra tradition to cite
the opponent's opinion first known as
the prior faction the port of obnoxio
Tufts it's actually a wing and it's like
right wing and left wing in British
Parliament and in our politics important
means the one that comes first so the
poor of a potshot is the prior faction
and they'll cite that often without
explicitly noting that it is in the
author's view incorrect and then to
state the office own correct opinion
setting up opponents as strongmen and
then demolishing them both kalki lea the
author of the artist roster and
Vatsyayana the author of the Kama Sutra
well also sometimes both older scholars
or opposing schools in order to say
rather extreme things that they really
believe themselves but do not want to
hold as their own to get them on the
table and then say oh no don't do that
in what's the matter that a lawyer might
reveal evidence to a jury and then when
reprimanded by a judge say the jury will
disregard those remarks it's not always
easy to tell apart these two agendas
setting up strong strong men to demolish
and using stalking horses to say what
you yourself do not dare to say outright
since they both take the same form of
ostensible disagreement the poor proxy
technique that serves their ass were
shocked the artists Shastra and the
kamasutra as a very useful way of
challenging Dharma without seeming to
challenge it for example the artists
house besides and dismisses the opinion
of earlier scholars on the way to deal
with the Kings potentially patricidal
sons as soon as they're born starting
from the siege
that the king killed them at birth and
concluding with a suggestion that he had
them corrupted or addicted by pleasures
how to Leah let's the spark with the
scholars quarrel among themselves and
then having put on the table in the
mouths of other people a number of truly
diabolical suggestions that may never
have occurred to anyone but Kathy Leah
he caps the argument with his own less
violent though still rather heartless
advice quote if he's an only son who was
dear to him the king should imprison him
if he has many sons the king should
banish him to the frontier or to another
region that's as good as it gets with a
crown prince the word for scholars
acharyas generally a term of great
respect in ancient India and the word
normally used to designate previous
authorities within the tradition that
one is writing about that word scholars
is mocked in the artists Shastra when
cotillion objects to a ludicrous rule
attributed to scholars calling it mere
wordplay
the word scholars almost has the
pejorative tone in the Kama Sutra
perhaps best translated as pedants
the Kama Sutra cites its standard list
of scholars in a debate about whether or
not women have lorg Azam's as men do
presenting the cockamamie theory of to
earlier scholars such as that women
don't have orgasms but have worms inside
them that produce an itch that demands
to be scratched before stating and
defending against objections by several
interlocutors but CIA's own sensible
opinions that they do have orgasms like
those of men two chapters later he
states but China says that is to say I
say since learned men disagree and there
are discrepancies and what the Dharma
texts say one should act according to
the custom of the region and one's own
disposition and confidence note vaginas
casual scorned for the text of Dharma
and is awareness of their self
contradiction
as well as his preference for individual
conscience these scholars of us have
many uses by situating his text is
merely a compilation of previous works
but the iana creates and then fully
utilizes a potential space for free
discourse and frank commentary on the
art and science of pleasure largely
devoid of the oppressive overlay of
dharma in order to understand precisely
how the artist roster on kamasutra got
away with this agenda it's useful to
make a distinction between two aspects
of religion orthodoxy believing the
right thing and orthopraxy doing the
right thing though the categories are
rather crude and there are exceptions in
general hinduism during the period in
question was far more autocrats and
orthodox Dharma regulated the way people
behave particularly toward Brahmins and
toward members of each caste more than
what they believed in particularly with
regard to the gods the oxford english
dictionary defines blasphemy as a
profane speaking of God or be sacred
things or see in pious irreverence the
ancient Indians had no concept of
blasphemy in the sense of a profane
speaking of God which is primarily a
monotheistic hang-up with so many gods
one could not help preferring one to
another and therefore inevitably sliding
some God or other and it did not matter
if you insulted gods who made no claim
to omnipotence or omniscience and
certainly not to benevolence this is
this changed in the later period the
bhakti period when parts of Hinduism
behaved a lot more like monotheistic
religions but I'm talking now of the
early centuries CE II and the last
centuries BCE and at this period I think
we really don't have the same
problems that arise with bhakti later on
would you talk about that but at this
time and for most Hindus even later
blasphemy in the sense of be profaning
sacred things such as the Veda the most
ancient and sacred texts of Hinduism and
see umpires a reverence to the Brahmins
the custodians of the Veda was indeed a
problem so you don't have the first kind
of blasphemy but you do have the second
and third kind a Dharma non Dharma or
anti Dharma we can call it on Dharma the
opposite of Dharma is not type one
blasphemy which no one really cared
about on Dhamma means two and three not
behaving properly offending the Vedas
and or Brahmins and you could get into
big trouble for that the oddest österlen
Kama Sutra therefore were able quite
confidently to get away with what Nandi
and news might regard as blasphemous
attitudes to the Hindu gods but they
were far more circumspect and what they
said about Brahmins and this is
something I'll return to in the final
lecture for instance Manu the lawmaker
does not mention any punishment for
verbal abuse of the gods but he
prescribes serious fines for the verbal
abuse of Brahmins depending upon the
class of the offender higher fines for
the lower classes and he continues quote
if a man of low birth hurls cruel words
at a Brahmin his tongue should be cut
out if he mentions his name or caste
maliciously a red-hot iron nail ten
fingers long should be thrust into his
mouth if he is so proud as to instruct
ramens about their duty the king should
have hot oil poured into his mouth and
ears
end quote the artist's officer is far
more lenient than this in its
prosecution for verbal abuse the artist
roster prescribes for all classes unlike
Manu who discriminates sharply between
them fines but no physical punishment
for quote insults relating to body
character learning occupation and
country for an insult relating to the
body with the words such as one
and lane and the fine is doubled if the
insult is untrue a circumstance which
Mun who does not take into consideration
at all the artists are excuse me the
artists Shastra also prescribes fines
for disdain couched as trays of people
who are one-eyed Lane and the like
saying what beautiful eyes you have and
for referring to people as lepers insane
or impotent but the artists austere
occasionally does take class into
account these fines are doubled if it is
directed if the insult is directed at
superiors and it is halved if directed
at inferiors are done through negligence
intoxication or folly when someone of a
lower caste insults the character of
someone higher such as by saying vile
Brahmin this is the example of the
artist Shastra the fine is incrementally
increased depending on the degree of
difference between the classes and with
someone higher insult someone lower it
decreases depending on the degree of
difference the auto saucer also
describes fines for insults relating to
the learning of bards and the occupation
of artisans and performers who mono if
you recall from the first lecture
regards as onion Sultan or reliable
proof being themselves a blot on the
social landscape the arthashastra and
the kamasutra therefore had to tread
lightly in their critique of Dharma in
what they said were talking now about
words in what they said about brahmanas
and the Brahmin occupation of performing
religious rituals under the circumstance
it is a it is amazing that these two
texts said as much as they did the kama
sutra in particular managed a brilliant
end run around dharma how did they do it
their subversion of dharma managed to
lodged in the body of normative texts
and antinomian tradition a pervasive
underman agenda coated with a thin
veneer of dharma the worlds
the artists Ostrom the kamasutra largely
disregarded rather than challenged the
power of bronze the texts were
perpetuated by Brahmins no one else
wrote Sanskrit texts under the noses of
other more conventional traditional
uptight Brahmins this was no class
struggle these texts therefore had a
very limited direct effect on the actual
lives of most people in ancient India
well there are highly significant in
their implications for freedom of speech
for intellectuals but as we've seen in
the first lecture their indirect effect
may well have been widely diffused
through the general population that is
the way that Sanskrit texts were
translated orally and spread throughout
the population to this degree they
represent our james-scott of this great
institution has taught us to call a
hidden subversive transcript one of the
arts of resistance a form of soft power
getting people to do what you want
without a fight the art that the artist
roster and the Kama Sutra used somewhat
resembles the technique that Hollywood
producers adopted to get around the
strict moral code the so called motion
picture production code enforced by the
Hays office from 1930 to 1968 in the
1946 film The Postman Always Rings Twice
for example Lana Turner and John
Garfield seemed to succeed in committing
both murder and adultery which are
forbidden in the Hays office until at
the very last minute as they're driving
off into what appears to be a beautiful
sunset he loses control of the car while
kissing her and drives into a tree
gratuitous Lee and meaninglessly killing
her in Ocean's eleven 1960 Frank Sinatra
on the Rat Pack except execute a
brilliant an entirely successful robbery
of the Las Vegas casinos only to watch
at the last minute all their money get
burnt up in an incinerated coffin such
tacked-on endings allowed Hollywood to
violate the Hays office code against
successful adultery
successful murder in the body of the
movie similarly both the artists Oscar
on the Kama Sutra pretend to care about
Dharma and pay lip service to it at the
start and finish of the book like
bookends ranking in above Arta and kama
we saw that in the first lecture but on
almost every page of the text they
violate Dharma the artist osto by
advocating violence and trickery the
kama sutra by facilitating adultery
let's consider first the artist roster
and then the kama sutra in both cases
noting first the superficial nod to
dharma and then the more substantial
subversion of dharma the other sauce is
careful to say a great deal in defense
of Dharma right at the start the text
devotes an entire it rather short
chapter to Dharma including the laws for
the firm for social classes the general
moral law that applies to everyone and
the particular moral law that applies to
particular castes much of this reads as
if it could have been taken more or less
straight out of Manu simply putting
Manos verse into prose and in dealing
with the crown prince Kalia remarks once
you teach them what accords with Dharma
and artha never anything that is
contrary to Dharma and artha dharmic
dharmic advice of this sort related to
the control of the social community is
scattered throughout the artist Shastra
non-violence is part of the Dharma of
everyone performing your own caste
Dharma gets you to heaven and so forth
but many of the pro dharma statements in
the artist roster are lodged inverts
versus at the end of chapters which
should be to be tacked on as an
afterthought though they may in fact be
taken from earlier Pro Dharma texts just
as the statements in praise of the
triple set the three aims of human life
privilege ignore ma are tacked on in the
start and finish of the text as a whole
and highly disrespectful attitudes to
social Dharma and to the gods persist
throughout the presumably old pre manu
on
artist roster material emerges sin
regards the artist roster as quote
basically a secular treatise despite the
respectful gestures it makes to
religious and social customs end quote
we've considered these respectful
gestures to Dharma that is to say
religious and social customs but to the
extent that under Dharma can be
translated as secularity we might ask
what they're not only makes this text
secular but justify sends view that it
is a bulwark against religiosity and one
of the pillars of quote the reads of
public reasoning in India and the
diversity of its coverings and coat the
evidence for the secularity of the
artists Shastra is profuse and profound
the King's Education after a brief nod
to the Vedas was entirely secular and
scientific not religious nor does the
artist author always treat Brahmins with
the great respect that Manu demands for
them when a Brahmin commits a crime he
the King should proclaim it star him
with a mark and exile him so Brahmins
were not in theory at least entirely
immune to punishment in replenishing the
Treasury the Kings offers officers quote
should bring over the property of
religious orders or the property of
temples except what is meant for use by
Vedic scholars stating that it was
deposited with the person who was died
or whose house has been burned down the
temple superintendent should gather
individually the treasures belonging to
the temples of the city and bringing
them over in the same manner and quote
the King would therefore confiscate
religious property and he was told to
lie when he wanted to do it but he did
make the point of leaving Vedic scholars
alone so he's walking this tightrope a
truly appalling subversion of Dharma and
the artist Oscar occurs in one of the
tests that as we saw in the first
lecture the king is told to use to
choose his ministers the test for Dharma
is a test against Dharma a test to make
sure that
this Minister is impervious to Dharma it
begins when the king gets his chaplain
to pretend to object to an order given
by the king in violation of Dharma then
quote the king should then pretend to
dismiss him he should send secret agents
to instigate ex-minister that's being
tested instigate each minister
individually under oath saying this King
is on dharmic come on let's install in
this place some other dormant person
everyone likes this idea what about you
if he rebuffs it he is a man of
integrity that is the secret test
relating to Dharma and Crow in other
words you want your chocolate your chief
priest the person in charge of the
Dharma of the entire kingdom to be
someone who doesn't care about Dharma as
much as he cares about loyalty to the
king other officials - in the artist
Oscar might cause a loss of revenue if
they hesitate to act against Dharma you
want officials are impervious to moral
principles of any time another way in
which the artist hofstra seriously
undermines undermines Dharma is in the
widespread use of ascetics both male and
female as spies or the use of spies who
pretend to be ascetics it's never
entirely clear which either the King
bribes and corrupts genuine renouncers
or by getting his agents to impersonate
such people he sullies the reputation of
the real ones renouncers and Yogi's and
ascetic magicians already had a fairly
dicey reputation in ancient India and
the artists austere made a bad situation
even worse the basic orthopraxy of
Hinduism makes offenses against the law
of God's far less important than
offenses against Brahmins yet all three
of our texts sometimes act as if they
believe in the gods although their
attitudes to them different widely for
instance on several occasions mano
mentions Indra the Vedic king of the
Gods has a great God worthy of worship
and
tells the king to emulate him the our
testosterone kamasutra by contrast tell
the tale of indras punishment for
adultery as a cautionary tale a way that
the king should not behave and the our
testosterone kamasutra seem to have no
sense of divine sanctions for the rules
that they break in such a Cavalier
manner where a lack of respect for gods
blends over into the area of lack of
concern for sacrifice or temple rituals
however the arthashastra once again
comes into direct conflict with dharma
take the question of the divine nature
of the king manu basically argues that
the king is a god and you should obey
him quote even a boy king
should not be treated with disrespect
with the thought he is just a human
being but this is a great deity standing
there in the form of a man and in court
and to support the statement man who
tells the myth of the origin of the
first king created to save the world
from the chaos of anarchy and return for
his protection the people agreed to pay
him one-sixth of their produce in taxes
how Thalia quotes the same myth of
Anarchy but cynically instructing the
king to have his spies spread the story
among the people to shut down dissent to
make them fear the king and pay their
taxes manipulating the myth of primeval
anarchy in order to control the gullible
we noted in the first lecture the artist
Oscar use of actors in one noteworthy
passage spies this as gods of fire and
water to demoralize the enemy during the
siege quote the king when he desires to
capture an enemy settlement should
embolden his own faction and terrify his
enemy's faction by proclaiming his
omniscience and his intimacy with gods
the proclamation of intimacy with gods
however is as follows conversing with
and worshiping agents posing as dogs of
a fire sanctuary agents who have entered
the hollows of divine statues in the
fire sanctuary
through an underground tunnel or
conversing with and worshipping agents
disguised as Nagas serpent deities and
Valona god of the waters emerging from
Mordor this sort of divine impersonation
was used on other occasions - we're
trying to raise more money after
stealing from the temples the King could
play theological tricks of his own Oh
having erected a divine shrine or a holy
place of a magician at night claiming
that it arose spontaneously he should
make a living through pilgrimages and
fairs or he should publicize the advent
of the divinity via a tree in a
sanctuary bearing flowers and fruit out
of season or after disclosing the danger
of a demon in a tree demanding a human
being as attacks agents working
undercover as ascetics should counteract
it for the people of the city and
countryside in exchange for money or for
a monetary gift he should show a snake
with several heads in a well equipped
with an underground tunnel he should
show to credulous people the site of a
snake put into a trance with food in a
snake statue containing a cavity within
it or in a hole of a sanctuary or he's
to replenish the Treasury by
counteracting occult appearances and if
there's anyone who's not taken in by
these tricks the king can always fall
back upon the usual solution quote in
the case of those who are not prejudiced
after administering poison to them when
they are sipping water or washing he
should declare to be a curse of the
deity end quote there are lots of these
how could a king who believed in the
gods consent to mock them in such ways
as this and it gets worse the statues of
gods come in handy as murder weapons
first they are used merely to demoralize
the enemy quote from highly honored
statues of gods they should cause an
excessive flow of blood then others
should say that the flow of God's blood
predicts defeat in a war
and full but then they're actually used
to kill crow during the pilgrimage for
worshipping of divinity there were
numerous places that the enemy will
visit to pay homage according to his
devotion at these places the king should
employ trickery upon him upon him as he
enters a temple he should make a false
well or a stone fall by releasing a
mechanical device or set off a shower of
stones or weapons from an upper chamber
or let a door panel plunge or release a
door bar attached to a wall and secured
at one end or he should make the statue
banner or weapons of the god fall upon
him and quote this scenario straight out
of Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
is also attributed to here of Alexander
in the 1st of 2nd century CE II who made
the same sort of machines to trick
people and in the Arabian Nights a pagan
King employs a man to slip inside the
idol and give out the Oracles from
within the statue but apparently unlike
the king in the artist Oscar the pagan
King does not use the idol to kill the
supplicants what about the Kama Sutra
let's see Ayane offers a defense of
Dharma against imagined materialists
whose arguments he states in the useable
pour of a box I remember that's the
wrong argument and then rebus so he
first quotes materialists and then
defends Dharma against them so materials
have said Dharma is no good and then he
answers in rebuttal people should act
within Dharma because the text cannot be
doubted because sometimes black magic
and curses are seen to bear fruit
because the constellations moon Sun
stars and the circle of the planets are
seen to act for the sake of the world as
if they thought about it first because
social life is marked by the stability
of the system of the four classes and
the four stages of life and because
people are seen to cast away a seed in
their hand for a sake of a
in the future in coal so perhaps by
positioning himself as a stout defender
of the stability of the system of the
four classes but the iana is subtly
seeking the support of the religious and
secular critics of his work and
undermining their criticism of a text
dedicated to pleasure the Kama Sutra at
the very start nods to Dharma as it
introduces its section on the women with
whom one should and should not have sex
quote comma enjoyed according to the
texts with a woman who was of a man's
own class and who has not been with
another man before is a means of getting
sons a good reputation and social
acceptance but that but in the first
sentence introduces a long long list of
other sorts of women that one may enjoy
if one is not particularly concerned
about class son's reputation or social
acceptance and Eden introduces the
entire rest of the text one of the
rationalizations for having sex with a
woman from the category one should not
have usually takes Dharma into
consideration the man made these aspo
the man may think this is a loose woman
she's already ruined her virtue with
many other men even though she is of a
class higher than mine I can go to her
as I would go to a courtesan without
offending against Dharma she's a second
hand woman sister no the man has kept
her before me there's no reason to
hesitate about this for these and
similar reasons one may seduce even the
wife of another man in court so the
danger offending against Dharma and the
issue of class is considered but quickly
rationalized away record assisted Dharma
in the kama sutra the relatively rare
sometimes occur in surprising contexts
this is one of my favourite ones the
courtesan wonders will I serve Dhamma or
violate it if I go
on the sympathetic advice of a friend to
a Brahman who knows the vada or to a man
who's under a vow of chastity or
consecrated for a sacrifice or a man who
has taken a vow of chastity or who wears
the sign of a religious order if he has
seen me and the concede conceived the
passion for me and wants to die if I
don't come to him end quote
in other words she would violate Dharma
in one way if she allowed or helped a
man of chastity to violate his vows but
she would violate it in another way if
she let him die through his unsatisfied
passion for her she is caught between a
rock and a hard place the Kama Sutra
elsewill remarks that when a man sees
that his desire is progressing from one
stage to the next then in order to ward
off these fatal blows to his own body he
should make advances to other men's
wives this escape clause apparently also
applies to men under religious vows
Dharma slips in in another unexpected
spot - in the Kama Sutra enlisting the
reasons why a married woman might resist
our hero's invitation to betray her
husband one of the scholars were in the
port of EPOXI now the other guys says a
woman does not consider Dharma or under
MA she just desires but consideration of
some other factor keeps her from making
advances a man by contrast considers the
stability of Dharma and the conventions
of noble people and turns back even when
he desires and even when he is pursued
he does not give in because he's aware
of these considerations mine too but
China by no means necessarily agrees
with this view which in any case merely
tells us what people do not what they
ought to do but but the INA himself
contradicts at least the first sentence
a woman does not consider Dharma when he
lists as the very last in a long list of
the causes of a woman's resistance the
possibility that she has regard for
Dharma in contrast with these few
scattered ambiguous positive references
to Dharma
the kamasutra by endorsing adultery in
an entire book of the seven books
devoted to it is undermining the very
basis of the social system and that's
where it is truly bold
moreover where the art artists Shastra
constantly opposed the systems of both
caste and class which are at the heart
of the social law advocated in the
Dharma texts the Kama Sutra in contrast
with almost all other Shastras of this
period largely ignores caste and class
there are only four references to class
in the hold of all peripheral we've
already seen two of them in this
consideration of women of the same class
the Kama Sutra portrays an idealized
form of the actual lives of wealthy
wealthy people who did not necessarily
follow the rules of Dharma in defending
the need for a Kama Sutra but china says
scholars say member this is other guys
pedants pedants say quote since even
animals manage sex by themselves and
since it goes on all the time it should
not have to be handled with the help of
a text but this is an argument why read
the Kama Sutra but China says because a
man and a woman depend upon one another
in sex it requires a method and this
method is learned from the Kama Sutra
the meaning of animals by contrast is
not based on any method because they
made only when the females are in their
fertile season and until they achieve
their goal and they act without thinking
about it first
end quote thus vagina dismisses with one
or two short sentence the scholars
dharmic assumption that the purpose of
the sexual act is to produce children
given the enormous emphasis that the
Dharma text place on having sex only to
produce children and mother's insistence
that a man must have sex with his wife
in her every fertile season and never at
any other time which the artists austere
echoes and agrees with the kama sutras
assumption that people differ
precisely in their ability to have sex
separate from fertility is wildly anti
dharmic and highly scientific but the
most dramatic instance of the
irrelevance of Dharma for the kama sutra
comes when the kama sutra actually
defines dharma
it says dharma consists in engaging as
the text decree and sacrifice and other
such actions that are disengaged from
material life because they're not of
this world and their results are
invisible and Dharma consists in
refraining as the texts agree from
eating meat and other such actions that
are engaged in material life because
they are of this world and the results
are visible and quoted but generally
here totally dismisses the role of
Dharma in this world a role that as
we've seen he cites with approbation in
his defence of Dharma just a few lines
later fold because social life is marked
by the stability of the system of the
four classes and the four stages of life
ignoring ma news Dharma the social
aspect of Dharma the Dharma of what you
should eat and whom you should marry but
China here seems to confuse in the
theology or philosophy yet in this
earlier defense of Dharma is approval of
doing something for the sake of what you
can't see
sowing seeds for the future is an
affirmation of the otherworldly aspects
of Dharma but it is in the casual
suggestions that pervade the book that
we can best see the kama sutras
total disregard for Dharma but China
cites an earlier authority on the best
places to pick up married women of worth
which the first is on the occasion of
visiting the gods and others include a
sacrifice a wedding or a religious
festival somehow I don't think Mona
would approve the man in question
meeting married women at all let alone
using devotion to the gods as an
occasion for it in general the Kama
Sutra
the kind of sexual freedom for women
that would have appalled Manu that
simply does not interest calcula but
china tells us that a woman who done
does not experience the pleasures of
love may hate her man and leave him for
another if as the context suggests this
woman is married a casual manner in
which possess - suggests that she leave
her husband is in sharp contrast to the
position assumed by Manu quote a
virtuous wife should constantly serve
her husband like a God even if he
behaves badly freely indulges his lust
and is devoid of any good qualities and
problem but shagging a casually mentions
among the women one might sleep with not
only secondhand women but widows who
Manu
positively forbids to remarry the Kama
Sutra says quote a widow who was
tormented by the weakness of the census
finds again a man who enjoys life and is
well endowed with good qualities and for
having left the guy who had no qualities
at all in Manu and the artist Shastra
male homoerotic activity was punished
albeit mildly a ritual bath according to
Manu or the payment of a small fine
according to the artist Shastra the
artist Asura specifies punishments for a
man who has sex with a female wandering
ascetic or with a prostitute by force or
with a woman in a place other than the
vagina or for ejaculating in a man or
the vaginas of animals or for many men
raping a single prostitute
Manu forbids a man to shed his semen in
non-human females in a man in
menstruating women in something other
than a vagina or in water the Kama Sutra
ignores some of these acts and regards
others as non criminal although in bad
taste but it departs from the dharmic
view of homosexuality in significant
ways principally by not regard
it has a crime at all in place of the
conventional law against sex between men
it describes in totally non-judgmental
language two types of men who make their
living performing oral sex on other men
one is a cross-dressing male with
stereotypical female gender behavior the
other a closeted man who dresses in
man's clothing and whose fellatio
technique the Kama Sutra describes
inconsiderable sensual detail in the
longest consecutive passage in the text
describing any physical act and with
what might even be called gusto the Kama
Sutra also describes men who engaged in
oral sex not by profession but out of
love who seemed bound to one another by
discriminating affection rather than
from mischievous passion nowhere else in
the entire corpus of ancient Sanskrit
literature is there a positive portrayal
of men who have sex with men but the
most significant divergence between the
two texts are testosterone Kama Sutra on
the subject of sexuality is their
attitude to adultery money tells you to
kill the adulteress the artist also
tells you to forgive her or mutilate her
and the Kama Sutra to find a way to get
her to go to bed with you more precisely
the outer source of regards of adultery
is a legal crime as does Manu
although the argos Oscar goes into far
more detail than money when it comes to
the punishment of the adulterous couple
mano says if a woman who was proud of
her relatives of her own qualities
deceives her husband with another man
the king should have her eaten by dogs
in a place frequented by many people and
he should have the evil man burned on a
red-hot iron bed and people should pile
wood on it and the evildoer should be
burned up and quote the outter sauce was
more lenient quote if the husband were
to forgive her both the woman and her
lover should be set free if she is not
forgiven the woman
ears and nose should be cut off and her
power more shall be put to death
none of this is in the Kama Sutra which
devotes an entire whole book book five
to mine news and psychotic
psychologically acute instructions of a
man who wishes to commit adultery
detailing hundreds of stratagems by
which the man about town may sleep with
the wives other men and it merely pulls
back at the very end with a Hays office
warning the man warning to the man not
to do it and to guard his own wife let's
look at that passage so after telling
you chapter after chapter what make sure
the husband's out of town all the time
and at the end he says in verse a man
who knows texts and considers from the
text the devices who tell those telltale
signs are detailed in the discussion of
the production of other men's wives is
never deceived by his own wives but he
himself should never seduce other men's
wives because these techniques show only
one of the two sides of each case
because the dangers are clearly visible
and because it goes against both Dharma
and artha this book was undertaken in
order to guard wives for the benefit of
men its arrangement should not be
learned in order to corrupt the people
and quote yeah sure but but china
manifests his ambivalence about sexual
freedom at many points in his book
particularly in the verses at the end of
each chapter which often raise doubts
about matters that he has recommended in
the prose passages which one expresses
let see I in his own opinion we've noted
in the Kama Sutra and our disaster the
tension between Dharma and ungawa
but the Kama Sutra has a third factor to
take into account the first level the
bulk of the work is in prose describing
all the things that a person could
possibly do many of these such as
adultery and homosexuality violate
Dharma but that Serena seems to feel
duty-bound to mention
in order to cover the full spectrum of
possibilities as the fits a Shastra a
JAMA that boasts of totality would say
more about that you're supposed to cover
the whole subject in the Shastra so for
China it tells you everything he's ever
heard him that people could do sexually
the second level inverse at the end of
chapters insists on the rules of Dharma
but there's also a third level on which
but China seems to be expressing his
personal distaste for certain certain
actions regardless of their dharmic or
on dharmic status sometimes he says that
such things are done in the South but
China probably came from partly put her
in the North sometimes he says that only
country folk will do them never
sophisticated Cosmopolitan's and
sometimes he simply falls back upon a
kind of Dharma of individualism listen
to your own conscience don't just do
what the text says and always have a
care for your partner's individual
tastes and physical capable capacities
it is on this third level outside the
scope of Dharma and under that but China
seems most secular and most rational
thus in conclusion free and unfettered
discourse existed in this period in
Indian history primarily in the realm of
comma in the third lecture next
Wednesday I'll explore another realm in
which the secular tradition lived on but
much quoted for perhaps non-existence
set of people variously referred to as
skeptics and materialists the artist
roster and Kama Sutra with their near
total disregard for Dharma show a
striking converse with materialist
assumptions the artist Shastra cites
with approval the so called materialists
of loci attest and are frequently who
are frequently cited always with
disapproval in later texts as well
including a Kama Sutra to this extent
these charvaka says they're called these
materialists carry on the legacy of the
scientific Shastras sniping away at
Dharma but did the chakras exist or did
they eventually become whether or not
they ever were real a useful figment of
the Hindu imagination with achill
strongmen that allow ancient texts to
express skeptical ideas without taking
responsibility for them come back on
Wednesday
okay the floor is now open for questions
while you're gathering your thoughts and
getting ready I should remind you that
there as with last time there are two
microphones on either side of the room
and it's really important that you
approach the microphone ohs begin to
other lectures being recorded we want to
hear your question and not only the
answer one final reminder there will be
a reception please join us you're all
very welcome after this talk and as well
as after the final talk on Wednesday
which will be back in the old room that
is in Luce Hall also at 4:30 and as you
ask your question please introduce
yourself thank you for joining uh I'm
Nikki and I I attended your previous
lecture where you mentioned that it was
quite likely that a young courier read
the de laws of Manu in the during the
day and the Kama Sutra at night but it
really seems from this lecture that
these three kind of addressed slightly
different audiences or like someone who
enjoyed reading Manu would really be
would find the Kama Sutra distasteful so
do you really think this happened and if
it did how did people reconcile the two
texts in there it's a good question
they are certainly addressed to
different sorts of assumptions about the
world that is to say laws of money was
soon like you're gonna bei the rules and
you're gonna do the right thing or the
one who also says if you don't obey the
rules this is what to do so he knows
that people do make mistakes the artist
just was addressing the king
theoretically in telling him how to run
the country and other people might read
it as one would be the legal text to
find lawyers and the ancient in England
of people the village panchayats the
people who decided legal cases is this
woman ever right whose property is this
this guy says it's - oh so that's who
would primarily read the
artists Shastra the commercial will be
read by people of leisure people have
privileged people who are looking for
ways to have a good time and so forth of
course a lawyer could also have a good
time and someone who was cared about
Dharma could also care about law so in a
way it's rather like I would say people
who scientists who geologists who know
about the history of planet Earth and
how to date it and who work all week
etiology and paleographic materials and
go to church on Sunday and read the
creation of the world in Genesis and
enjoy that - in a different way
so I think it's possible there were
different audience but it's also
possible at a single person certainly a
scholar might read all three texts out
of interest the other thing to say is as
in the past is that really important
passives in the Kama Sutra belief about
how even if you can't read Sanskrit you
might get to know the text in other ways
that's a really important text that I
think is very often too often ignored
people say oh well only Brahmins read
Sanskrit so this text is very early no
one knew about it everybody knew about
it people in India offenses know the
plot of the Ramayana they don't read
Valmiki Sanskrit texts so in the same
way these ideas are largely diffused
people know what Manu says a lot of
people hated money for what he said
banda was burnt in the 19th century well
thought to be because of the caste
system and people say oh the artist
Oscar says you know always kick a man
when he's down even if they haven't read
the Sanskrit texts and people say the
Kama Sutra says you can really do this
and so forth and you should chew beta
laughter you make love and things like
that so in the broader sense they were
diffused promiscuously throughout
society and in the even in the Sanskrit
sense although they're addressed to
different people in one way the ideas
are more broadly available they conflict
but people do have conflicting ideas and
wear different hats so so I'm saying
that they have very different ideas
about Dharma
but at the same time people have various
ideas about Dominic in this quite
conceivable that one person would read
and enjoy in different ways all three
texts so it's a good question yes hi
thanks so much
my name is Seth so I think that this is
somewhat related to the last question
I'm very interested in all the examples
that we've been hearing from the artists
Shastra yeah
and I'm curious it would seem you know
if these authors are writing this that
they would that they had intended for
these examples to be really you know say
the tests in you know of a cleric or
something like that
in the artist Shastra if that was you
know presumably meant to be taken
seriously or if there's other literature
around that is doing things like this
and it's just a rhetorical device that
would be it's for the first question so
on the side of the authors are these
meant to be taken seriously and then on
the side of the audience where they
thought to be taken seriously or were
they just rhetorical devices perhaps
it's a really good and really
unanswerable question in some ways all
of these texts are highly idealized if
you read the Kama Sutra carefully it
tells you what you're supposed to do all
day long in the morning you this is the
guy right there morning he shaves and
then he has food brought to him and then
he trains his mind heard to speak and in
the afternoon he goes on a picnic and
then in the evening he goes to visit
people they play music and they dance
and you wonder does he every visit his
mother you know does he ever again what
does he do about it stockbroker you know
you know if he's that kind of a guy
where is the rest of his life it's sort
of like the Playboy ideal you know Hugh
Hefner in ancient world so obviously
very few people ever actually lived like
that but but those are all possibilities
some people train minor birds to sing
and some people had concerts at night so
it's kind of condemned
to an idealized world in the same way my
colleague Sudhir Kaka of once figured
out that man who has so many rules about
the days when you can't have sex with
your wife that if you followed all the
rules in mono so you can't have sex with
your wife when she's not fertile so
that's just a part of the month you
never on the even days you get a
daughter you don't want a daughter so
you have sex on the odd days you can't
have sex in certain phases of the Moon
you figured out you can have sex - seven
days a month if you actually follow all
the rules in Manu
so he's really saying you should try not
to do this so money was idealized the
Kama Sutra is idealized the artists
hostel I think is idealized in a wicked
way no one no kings killed all their
sons I mean you just that's an insane
idea you're worried about your son
taking over when he gets when he grows
up killing this is not good advice this
is this is the extreme form so they're
all in some ways pushing the envelope
into extreme areas but they show us what
the ideals were and the ideals are very
important so the ideal of the Kama Sutra
was just have fun all the time the ideal
of Manu was always a bear the rules all
the time the ideal of the other sauce
was do anything at all to gain power and
that's what we get from them really the
other thing to say is besides the ideals
the details are really interesting and
the details have have a feeling of
realia to them so when he describes the
sorts of foods you're supposed to serve
at a party when the courtesans come to
visit you you see what people ate they
had little bits of meat on on sticks
like you have an hors d'oeuvre sand
things like that and he says after you
make love you shouldn't look at each
other because you're all messed up you
go off to shower and then when you come
back you know there are sort of nice
things that probably happened so there
are a lot of really specific I think
realia moments but the overall picture
of the text is idealized and so you have
to make
you have to maneuver between those when
you say did people really do this or not
I think they did the specific things I
don't think they swallowed the whole
idea
that's mess my compromising itself doing
what it's a good Christian living
good to see you I'm Seth Sanders and I
actually think the first lecture I ever
heard on religion was dreams illusion
and other realities and she gave in
seventh grade so that description in the
of all the stratagems to use and abuse
gods in the art of Shastra struck me in
some way as being like the story that
Machiavelli tells about my news Anna
Grammatik relative nuuma in the
discourses on Livy but but of course
Machiavelli is is doing that as part of
a critique of religion and you know
Christianity too is are the things that
the author of the art of Shastra says
about the tricks you do with God's do
you think it implies that kind of a
sweeping critique of religion or is it
something else I don't I don't see it as
a critique of religion i I see this as
total disregard of religion I mean if
you believe in a God even if you believe
that there might possibly be a God in
that temple would you really put a spy
in it and have the statue thrown down on
somebody so that's the part of the
artist roster that implies no belief in
drugs there's another piece there's a
limit what you can do in one lecture but
in the book I'll talk about more he
tells the king to indulge in sacrifice
before a war and obviously there are
public sacrifices for that for the
masses right and I could think of Monty
Python you know blessing the sacred
grenades and all that sort of thing but
he also tells the King to have a private
sacrifice and the only way I can figure
that it is either there is
no privacy for a king everybody knows
that the king is privately praying now
or he's indulging in Pascal's wager
there just might be God so it doesn't
hurt to hedge your bets and do a little
bit of sacrificing so there were these
moments when it seemed that he might
think that there's a possibility that
gods exist but most of it you couldn't
possibly do these things dress up as
gods and have the guy who walk around
with the king if you believe that there
was visually it's just this is an
example but you have people dress as
Vishnu if you believe that there was a
Vishnu so it seems to me he's just
simply disregard of the gods the people
are gullible these idiots they believe
in God's okay pretend there are gods for
them it just seems to me an
extraordinarily cynical added toward
religion as world religion in in these
tricks that he plays and set up a guy in
a tree pretend there's human sacrifice
pretend there's a demon there he's
dealing with superstition which he
regards as merely superstition and he
blends it in the thing about the God in
the temples in the same paragraph as
pretend there's a god that a demon in
the tree he just thinks it's all
stupidity people are gullible use
religion it's bad attitude I think in
that sense it is a spectacular critique
of religion only idiots believe there
are gods
I mean it just seems to me that way I
think we have time for one last question
yes I'm sort of concerned about this
notion of the text being idealized
centuries over centuries just exist
disembodied from any communities that's
in laban from any any group of people
any power structures that aspect of any
social routing it in any social
structures just completely absent so I
wonder why you think you do that
that one first I must say he's idealized
him that it was irrelevant to what
people did people read it and may have
taken its advice I simply say that as as
the and I say that's the reality all
right there are all sorts of things in
it that people really did he tells you
how to attach different there really
I've given you the the creme of the
creme de la creme of the artist hasta
most of it is extremely boring it's long
list of how much can you pay to go over
a bridge if you have a four-wheeled cart
how much you pay go over bridges if you
have an 8 wheeled cart and so forth and
that sort of stuff obviously is part of
a rules of governing governing a kingdom
so there's a lot of it which was
absolutely applied and used he tells you
the different oaths that you make people
swear in court depending on their class
there's a lot of nitty-gritty useful
stuff yeah I would say I'm saying the
extreme weird parts of kill your son and
so forth like that are are idealistic
parts of it where it's idealized a kind
of pure self-serving materialism which I
think cannot have well I mean it would
seem to me certainly there's a Dharma
for the king the king can kill and
punish a lower class person cannot so
sort of subversive non dharmic texts
covered by a thin veneer of Dharma for
certain classes but there are classes
which have to toe the line and do the
patience of the Dharma so no I I find
that sort of missing your analysis about
about the reality well then I know there
though if the one could might even be
able to trace some of those rules
there's a point I want to make because I
don't want a teacher at the time okay so
it's idealized in another way for
instance in in in Manu one of the most
serious crimes is a young male student
seducing the gurus wife this is Manu
thinks this is a major crime in ancient
India because it must have happened all
the time because you have all these Oh
gurus with young wives who take young
male students in right this is a formula
for disaster and so it is the defining
crime who do toppika going to the guru's
bed and so manu says there's there are
two possible punishments for it one is
if you've committed the crime of
sleeping with your girl's life you
should castrate yourself and hold the
severed testicles in your hand and walk
to the northwest until you die or you
can drink a mixture of cow's urine and
several other things and fast for three
days now which one are you gonna do
right this is a no-brainer obviously
people who wanted to expiate the sin its
likes Hail Marys you the priest tells
you what to do would have drunk the
lousy stuff and the idea the idea that
you would castrate yourself and walk
until you dies and idealized
punishment this is what should be really
done to someone who does not allow
somebody in power to actually do that or
enforce it thank you everybody just
drank the cow urine I'd like to mention
it's in Buddhist texts you have a lot of
the same kind of things about what Kings
do very bad so that's another world
entirely that's not it no not at all and
one of the things it does is that it
allows Kings to behave badly Kings
behave badly all the time they have the
power to do so that's what it is to be
king is to have the power to behave
better and there's an idea in Buddhism
that perhaps the king can never really
be moral well that's it let me answer
that is the last Christmas yeah do me
zeal wrote about this years ago and and
the Indian texts are very much aware of
it the king has the duty to punish
that's the most important thing a king
does therefore the king has to inflict
capital punishment a great deal
therefore the king kills a great deal
and therefore the King needs to have a
powerful putahi the powerful chaplain at
hand at all times he has to be
constantly restored from his state of
pollution from doing his job as king and
there's a great deal of material
throughout the indo-european bird I
think George dionisio wrote about this
as well as anybody else and it's not
just India but it's it's very
brilliantly developed in India that the
king must sin the King is by definition
a sinner because of the need to take
life and therefore he can only function
in constant cooperation with the putto
Heath with the royal chaplain who
absolves him day after day so he can go
on doing his job
so that's built into not only the Indian
but the free Indian ancient
indo-european concept of kingship so
that - please join me in giving our
speaker a hand